one time I saw someone and there was
like what are you doing I thought I own
my own business and oh amazing and but
yeah yeah I've got an office in New York
I've got something like what if we was
running misguided marketing strategy
this is what we would do so often we
have to come up with PR idea social
ideas strategies of how we can convert
customers better than they are currently
and things like that I live in a cancer
State all my life so people didn't go to
UNI where I was from and I made it and I
did it and I proved everyone wrong he
would just be so proud so so but I don't
get me emotional he will just be so
proud and I think it's just because he
knows how resilient I am
um oh my God why am I crying what the
hell oh